-Seven years of "Scandal."
It´s really amazing.
-It´s crazy.
It´s crazy.
-And I think now,
it´s sort of easy to forget
what a big deal it was to be
an African-American female lead
on a network television show.
-It hadn´t happened
in a long time when we started.
It had been almost 40 years
since there had been
a black woman leading a TV show.
-That´s crazy.
-Yeah, it´s crazy.
-And I know there´s progress
still to be made,
but I really think that started
a trend of seeing more and more.
-Now there´s tons of shows
with black female leads.
-It´s great.
-It´s awesome!
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, also, you know --
And also, Indian-American leads.
-Yeah.
-southeast-Asian and Asian
and Latin, and all kinds
of people leading shows,
which is true, ´cause
all kinds of people live lives.
-Yeah, it´s good.
There´s a lot of stories
to tell about those lives.
-Yeah, that´s right.
-The other thing that
I feel started with "Scandal,"
or at least I became aware of,
is you guys really connected
with your fans online.
-Yeah.
-The live-tweeting.
-Had an intense live-tweeting
connection with your fans.
Will you miss that?
-I think so.
I think when people
ask me, like,
"Oh, what are the things
you´ll miss about playing her?"
It´s a little hard,
´cause I don´t --
It´s a little bit like asking me
what it´s gonna be like
to break up with somebody
I´m still in love with.
-Yeah, right.
-Right? Like I really
still love the show, and we´re
still having a great time.
But I am.
I´m gonna miss that community.
Like, every Thursday night,
the live-tweeting.
We´re, like, in it together,
experiencing these
crazy twists and turns.
-You watched it together.
-We did, as a cast.
-And this is just
a nice photo of the cast.
But I do have a question about
what glasses are you wearing?
-They´re strange
googly-eye glasses.
-Uh-huh.
-Because why not?
-Yeah.
-You in those glasses
is a bigger twist
than anything
I´ve ever seen on "Scandal."
[ Laughter ]
-I think Halloween is coming up.
-Yeah, right.
And, uh --
-Those are my eyes at the end.
It´s a big --
The ending of the episode...
Shocking results.
-See, that´s what
you should´ve said.
You should´ve said,
"Those aren´t glasses.
That´s what I saw -- the twist.
I was like, "Baang!"
-"Wha?!"
-And, uh --
-That is kind of how I felt,
really.
-I´ve heard you take a memento
from every part you play.
-I do.
-So, do you know
what you´re taking?
-Well, I can´t tell you
on national television,
because then, when
the Prada bags are missing...
-Oh, right, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But wait. Now, that
doesn´t seem like a memento.
That seems like you´re
just stealing a purse.
-But it´s --
It´s not one purse.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-It´s like 20 purses in various
colors to match every outfit.
-I thought it was gonna be,
"My lucky coffee mug."
But this is just theft.
-Oh, no, no.
They mean a lot to me,
these bags.
-Yeah, I bet.
-Seven years of memories
in every single beautiful bag.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It was a very
well-dressed character.
-She´s still living, by the way.
Not "was."
She is a very
well-dressed character.
-I´m so sorry.
-And she´s still carrying
Prada bags.
For 18 more episodes.
-That´s true.
I apologize.
I did not mean to rush ahead.
Let´s live in the moment,
enjoy the fact
that this is now a time
where it´s legal for you
to have those bags.
[ Laughter ]
And that time
will come to an end.
I´m saying this as your lawyer.
-Okay.
-You put this up
on social media.
You were -- You had very good
seats at a Boyz II Men concert.
-I did.
Look at that.
I did not zoom in.
That´s where I was sitting.
-Yeah, that´s great.
-It was amazing.
-How was the show?
-It was phenomenal.
They had roses.
Obviously,
when they sing "Bended Knee"...
for all of the older folks here.
-Wow.
-You know "Bended Knee"
is, like, a romantic song.
And I got a rose.
I was hoping I would get a rose.
-Wow.
How many roses do they have?
-They had like 70.
But I was excited to get one!
[ Laughter and applause]
-So, is it --
Now, how --
Does one of them hand out a rose
while the other guys
are refilling their roses?
-Well, they --
You know, they riff,
so the guy who´s singing
is the guy who hands the rose,
which means, like,
you get notes sung at you
while you´re getting the rose.
-Wow.
-It´s really extraordinary.
-I have a shameful thing
about Boyz II Men in my past.
-Why?
Do I want to know?
-Well, I don´t know.
Tell me if I should
feel ashamed about it.
-Okay.
Shame! Shame!
-Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah.
-And then, we will get
to "Game of Thrones,"
´cause I know
we share a love of that.
All right, so I was my class
treasurer in high school, okay?
-Oh.
-And I had to count the votes
for what the prom song was.
And what it should have been was
"It´s So Hard To Say Goodbye
to Yesterday,"
and I faked the vote
for something else.
[ Laughter, audience groans ]
-You were like
the Russian hacker
of the music at your prom?
-I hacked --
Yeah, yeah.
-That´s horrifying!
-And instead it was just a
spoken word Donald Trump album.
-Aah!
Aah!
-I feel bad.
I´ve always felt bad.
-What was the song
that you chose instead?
-A Van Morrison song.
It´s awful, yeah.
Talk about white privilege.
-Honestly!
-Yeah.
You should have these guys
on your show as reparations.
-Yeah, you´re right.
I should.
And then I´ll introduce
them and say,
"Now here to sing
are Boyz II Men,"
and then they´ll
just walk out in protest.
And they´ll be like,
"Why don´t you [bleep]
get Van Morrison?"
-They will take a bended knee.
They will take a bended knee.
-I owe them all roses.
I owe them all roses.